hey guys how's it going my name is Danny
and today I want to talk about these
concrete things also known as Brutalism
[Music]
like why would someone intentionally
design something so bland and imposing
people with absolutely no interest in
architecture have expressed a lot of
passion and hate for it
but if you talk to any architect or
architectural enthusiast and ask them
about Brutalism they're gonna say oh my
god Brutalism is so like you delight the
texture great poetry how can something
so beloved by one group of people also
be so hated by another Brutalism is very
interesting because it's not just about
the aesthetic of the style that made
them so popular but also the intent and
the morals behind it Brutalism became
popular in the 60s to the end of the 70s
but the mass use of concrete that
started much before that in the 1920s at
that time concrete was popping up
everywhere buildings bridges roads and
it was cheap you get into massive
quantities and it could span huge
distances and you could form them into
any shape that you wanted in fact
concrete is the second most consumed
product in the world after water so
after the Second World War a lot of
countries were torn apart and the
governments were strategizing on how to
rebuild these broken states while also
creating a perception of hope and social
change in the people and so they hired
architects and they funneled a lot of
money into creating this new vision the
governments entrusted architects with
complete freedom to test out their ideas
these architects they had a very strong
idea about what a socialist society
should look like and they couldn't
believe they were creating
spaces for the people in their buildings
they wanted complete honesty and
transparency and they wanted to show
exactly how they were built and what
they were made out of and what their
functions were they just left the
concrete raw they were against any sort
of symbols or ornamentation that were
pretty common in the styles that came
before them the manual labor to do these
delicate details were super expensive so
they believed that by getting rid of
them and highlighting only the
functional elements of the building they
believed that they were creating a new
Democratic building type what's
interesting is that to achieve this raw
natural look the sneaky architects were
actually going into the concrete and
detailing it to make it look more rough
which added to the manual labor so a lot
of these buildings focus on the public
spaces with massive atriums and
balconies that would spill out onto
walkways they had open stairwells and
corridors that people could just roam
around and they had lots of water
features and a lot of planters the one
little detail that they didn't realize
was that people don't really actually
like hanging out in these massive
concrete spaces so these faces became
neglected and it started attracting
unwanted activities concrete itself
deteriorates and weathers pretty badly
and the lack of maintenance kind of took
a toll and made them look really dirty
and terrible but aside from these little
failures I think these heroic socialist
ideals behind Brutalism is what really
gets architects going
and I think it's more interesting these
days because a lot of architects they
built for developers or capitalist
society and even when we're working for
the government the majority of us rarely
get that kind of creative freedom unless
you're Frank Gehry or yakking old and I
think the second reason is the quality
of the concrete itself it's really rare
these days to see a building where
concrete makes up the structure and the
cladding that's a massive thermal bridge
and it's probably a building a
scientists a worst nightmare
you have to insulate the outside of the
building to protect it from the cold to
keep the inside warm but the quality of
concrete is really interesting I think
concrete is almost like a natural
material but it's strong enough and
cheap enough to use for a large building
concrete is made with local aggregates
so the color and texture of the concrete
depends on the local climate and geology
so if you look closely every region it's
gonna have a different quality of
concrete concrete is also a very hard
material to work with and it's really
easy to screw up so anyone who's worked
with concrete knows that if we can get
it to be as beautiful as these brutalist
buildings then you deserve someone will
appraise actually one of the reasons I
decided to make the video was that I
found a reddit sub thread this was
actually in my first week quarantine
when I was kind of spiraling down the
black hole of Friday anyways I found a
subfloor as dedicated to Brutalism which
I found really interesting because it's
like one of the few architectural styles
that has its own reddit sub thread
especially interesting because my
experience of trying to talk to people
about architecture has never really been
that great I think one of the reasons
why Brutalism is becoming popular is
because they're so photogenic their
texture and their sharp
geometry and intense light conditions it
makes some perfect subject or backdrop
for a fashion photography and more than
ever before we consume architecture
through the screen rather than in person
so when we see the single shot of a
building that we never have to visit or
live in were suddenly drawn to their
radical quality one of the comments from
the reddit discussion was that they like
brutalist buildings because they're not
trying to be beautiful they kind of
stick out like a sore thumb in a sea of
agreeable buildings some would say it's
because they're so different because
they're so ugly because they don't give
- are they you know way kind of like
Bulldogs they're so ugly that they're
lovable do you think you could learn to
love these buildings so anyways that was
my brief introduction to Brutalism I
hope that was interesting for you guys
let me know what you think in the
comments below if you like this video
please like and subscribe and I'll see
you in the next video
you